let's just get into it let's talk about
the uh the first story so
uh for those that are just tuning in the
quick recap earlier today
the the the a.g announced the cops
involved in the briana taylor case
will not be indicted um in relation to
the death of bran taylor one shot uh one
one guy's getting charged wants an
endangerment
for firing i guess wildly or blindly
into other apartments nearly hitting
somebody
and so naturally now we're seeing civil
unrest we got the story from the new
york post
civil unrest in louisville intensifies
hours after brianna taylor grand jury
decision
obviously if you're tuning in right now
it's it's happening literally as we're
speaking so we're not we're not covering
any of the stuff live
and this story is from five we've
already seen a ton of arrests we've
already seen
people deploying shields a van pull a
u-haul pulls up they start giving out
materials
they've clearly been planning for this
in advance the city declared a state of
emergency i think what was it like
several days ago
saying like no parking in downtown and
they expect it to to go nuts
so today's only what wednesday this
weekend's gonna be absolutely insane
absolutely insane
so for for uh there's a lot to go
through here you know what i'm gonna do
i'm just gonna ask you you're
you do you know everything that happened
with the grand taylor case yep
and so for those that aren't familiar
this is uh maj toure
you founded black guns matter yep so
this is uh
what what are your thoughts on the brian
taylor case let's start to you first and
foremost
um love and respect to her family
uh her loved ones the people that will
never see her
again brianna taylor um
so i think that's it's fair to and
respectable to make sure that
we we lead with that energy for sure man
um
secondly state
is 100 responsible for brianna taylor's
death
unequivocally um now
if you want to get into the weeds and
the nuance of you know
the officers and why this part now
that's for all of my friends that live
in hoods across
america yes the state is absolutely
responsible for it
now when you get into the conversation
about the nuance and the objective
nature of
okay what happened like the facts of the
matter right
some of my friends may disagree with me
um
especially people that have been the
people that will agree with me
have probably either been in the
shootout shot at someone or shot had
someone shoot at them
um people that know what rounds do
will totally get why someone getting
shot at
will shoot back oh yeah um
so in that sense i want to again lead
with my primary thought is
the state government
which is useless which does not help
um we'll we'll get we'll get into that
later because we'll agree it's gonna be
fun they're responsible for
that death and when you get to a point
where you have someone issuing
re no not great not raid whatever i'm in
my house
i don't have to answer my door right i
don't have to
and if i don't answer my door and
whoever's on the other side of that door
that doesn't announce exactly who they
are and it's not clear who they are
if they break into my house i am well
within my means
to shoot them if you come into my house
after a certain
time unannounced i'm not answering the
door and if you kick my door in
i i here's the challenge man i think
i read through this stuff i read what
cnn had to say i read these like league
documents
i don't think anybody was wrong i mean
actually i would lean more towards the
the state itself and the system itself
was wrong
yeah so the cops are told to serve a
warrant they go the knock on the door
they say they announce themselves
witness witnesses apparently you know
saw them say what was going on
maybe maybe they didn't announce
themselves they said they did i don't
believe them i think they're
liars yeah i think they're liars i think
that just like they lied about saying
that
they talked to the postmaster and the
postmaster they got proof that the mail
was coming for the drug dealers and
all that to the house and the postmaster
general was like that's not true
that's not true they've proven
themselves to be liars
they're lying i do not believe that now
unfortunately regardless of if i believe
it or not
brianna's dead then they charged
kenneth walker for defending his house
and the only reason why he's out of jail
is because people started making an
uproar about it
yeah you know what i mean and any of
those officers if somebody did the same
thing
in their house those officers would have
did the same thing kenneth walker did
so that's the point i'm trying to make
yeah you break my door down
so i'm trying to you know i'm trying to
be that milk toast fence that are on
this one right
maybe it's not gonna work but the idea
the idea the idea is let's say the
benefit of the doctor the cops i you
disagree you think they're lying and uh
i respect that for sure
because of course everyone's gonna
protect their own interests right let's
say they did yell and kenneth just
didn't didn't hear anything so all he
sees is a door fly open people are
breaking his door down and he's like
my house my gun i'm defending myself
it's castle doctrine play dumb games win
stupid prizes yeah you break into my
house i'm defending myself it's not the
first time we've heard stories like this
too
where a cop you know they'll break in
and they're playing clothes
and even if they announce themselves
this is this is why i say
when i say it's not anybody's fault what
i'm trying to say it's the system's
fault right so i agree when you say the
state is responsible i think it's a
system we created
let's say the cop yells police you know
we're coming
in and you don't hear him and then you
see a guy in regular clothes armed with
a
gun
i'm shooting you right exactly even if
you do hear him
and anyone in the world could be like
it's the police open up
right exactly if they wanted to kill you
and then if you open the door and they
killed you so like if he thought that
someone was coming for him and he heard
someone yelling they came up with plain
clothes
i'm all the way with y'all we all in
essence saying the same thing
but then i got to go to why were you
lying
i cannot leave that part out which wh
the police officers saying and
and maybe not those yeah maybe not the
specific police officers on scene right
but their team starts to lie to protect
those officers oh yeah then you have a
scenario where
you tried to get the uh the ex-boyfriend
they tried to present him with the plea
deal to lie
on briana taylor bam and saying
say she was involved and we'll cut down
on your sentence shouts to him for not
being a coward
and taking the time taking those extra
years because he could have gotten off
light
but then there's back to back lies the
system the state
lying to protect their own this speaks
to bigger things
um so to your point though tim
the if i'm the officer that is getting
shot at
from a tactical standpoint i'm not just
shooting i'm not just returning rounds
right especially the first guy that got
charged his k his charges carry up to
five years
though that's that's the wanton
endangering guy yes yeah he shot
three apartments right right right you
don't know what you're doing
and the cops actually testified they
were telling him to chill out right that
was
when he was at the door he was like
really nervous and agitated and the
i can't remember where the cop which cop
it was he was saying bro relax he's like
brett relax relax brat relax right
now his name was brett the bigger
picture here is
okay this was about drugs as an ex-drug
dealer
allegedly right
drugs go like this hey man
i want some weed hey man
i have the wheat oh that's great i have
the money right here that's called
commerce and every other case right
tim is like i'm gonna rob maj tim
robs me and i go man tim just robbed me
i call the police they come get the
information
they do the investigation not in drug
cases they sit they lie they sneak they
put stuff on people the bigger other
question that's not being
statement that's not being said is this
is another clear-cut example that the
war
on drugs is an extreme failure oh yeah
and in this scenario
it cost brianna taylor her life kenneth
walker had to be in jail what couldn't
even attend
you know he had he had to deal with that
right the law enforcement officers could
have got killed one of them got shot in
the leg
yeah femoral femoral artery and that you
will bleed out
yup so these are things that we're we're
making it about the
okay these cops where i i do believe
that the one cop that was reckless
yeah i'm cool with that charge the other
two that were returning fire not in
three different
you know uh houses
those guys aren't charged because yeah
you guys were getting shot at that's the
part that people the objective part that
has to come down right
but the bigger issue is and i want to
say shouts to dr
paul for presenting legislation that
puts it into no knock raids not that
this was that
right they handled this the same way
that they handled uh the zimmerman case
television made it about the stand your
ground it wasn't a stand your ground
case like
at all at all so the bigger issue is the
war on drugs is a complete sham
it's putting respectable law enforcement
officers
i am not a status by any stretch of the
imagination
however i want guys to if that guy or
woman puts that uniform on and say
i'm going to catch some robbers some
rapists and some unjustified killers
today
and i'm going to make the community
safer i salute them but if you're
running around talking about yeah we
heard
that they had drugs the person that
wanted the heroin and
this person had the money you you see
that it's a failure and so i think the
bigger picture is having those
conversations in that regard
and i have to settle with the fact that
and it hurts i have to settle with the
fact that because of systemic
flaws this young woman will never be
able to see her family again
right you know you know when you talk
about cops lying i've seen it
and there was there was a case in new
york where i was i was live streaming
i'm on the sidewalk
and i was i didn't even realize what was
going on but apparently i filmed the
dude who got arrested
the cops lied so the woman who actually
felt the arrest report wasn't the one
who made the arrest
she claimed he was blocking the road
he's on video getting arrested on the
sidewalk
and i got angry like why was there no
accountability
for lying on that police report
arresting this dude nothing ever
happened
because the state can lie they can
lawyers
attorney generals district attorneys all
of that they can lie understand and
trick you
you know but if you lie in response they
can charge you
so here's the issue i see i recognize
that and when i hear stories that
you know cops will lie to protect each
other yeah what else is new people don't
hold their own groups accountable right
right here's the issue the far left does
the exact same thing these are like
extremists these rioters
they smash and burn and with a smile on
their face they'll lie about everything
they'll claim you know kyle right now is
a white supremacist
mm-hmm and he's just a kid who was you
know coming out and
shouts to kyle under duress
doing his thing and and lowering his
weapon when the dude has hands up
the dude the last guy who didn't get
shot because two guys put their hands up
this is actually in the lawyer's uh the
the video they put out yeah
and kyle immediately lowers his weapon
under duress is a good point
so there's the left will lie they'll
claim all these things about him
to protect themselves and i see that in
every single community i don't care if
it's the police i don't care if it's
anti-fun
people do this for their their
communities whatever it is the problem
we have
we rely on police to us i know you're
gonna disagree with me
i never i will never call the police
why is that my first interaction with
law enforcement and i and
be clear i've had law enforcement guys
diana
mueller who's three gun competition
shooter has been one of black guns
matters
uh staunches supporters she's a cop
though and she's
some of the things she's just never
gonna i'm like bro you're heavy handed
on certain issues because you're
20 years ex-law enforcement i have guys
that i
totally would trust my life with that
are law enforcement ken scott pervectis
group came down to the solutionary
summit
instructor of the year in my mind like
every year
right so it's not that i'm not objective
my experience
my lived experiences with law
enforcement until i started doing the
second amendment thing right have been
horrible my first experience with law
enforcement i worked at mcdonald's
i had a free class i went down in philly
i went to the gallery when the gallery
was a thing
i went to go buy clothes with like my
mcdonald's
paycheck and come back to class cop car
pulls in front of me
they put me on the hood of the car they
take the money i got i got like two
hundred dollars left
right they take they like yeah you are
hustling i'm like no no i work at
mcdonald's my uniform's in my bag
i got my check i just went to the
gallery i'm coming back
it took my money and they they'd be like
all right go to class i was like damn
you're not gonna like leave me money for
like a transpass
because you know i'm high school i'm
taking a train and they they threw me
ten dollars
and said you can get some tokens that's
my first experience with law enforcement
at like
15 and a half that's that civil rights
civil forfeiture
you're right just we're taking your
money because
it was not it wasn't civil it was we're
taking your money we thought she was
hustling because i was excited to put
the hustler's shirt on
that i bought with my hard-earned money
coming back to school i had a free
period a free class
i go i come back this is my first
experience with law enforcement
in the communities and and i argue on
both sides i get love and hate from both
sides because
that experience in urban america is a
different experience that maybe maybe
maybe in suburban america and if i'm
in a 10 block radius that i never leave
and three out of the
ten cops in my 10 block radius during
the time that i'm there
three of those are like horrible humans
that is my lived experience with law
enforcement
does that is that a scathing indictment
of all law enforcement absolutely not
so i'm in this weird vin middle of the
venn diagram
in regards to law enforcement so for me
and politics too because you're
libertarian
right so to me i'm not calling the
police
until like i shot somebody and i'm
calling him to come clean this up and
take a report
because if i shot somebody was
absolutely to pretend
to protect life protect and defend life
and it's a slam dunk it was like jason
voorhees
and it was like clearly that's the bad
guy maj stopped the bad guy
they're gonna throw me a party hey
police got one you know there's been a
shooting at wherever i'm wearing
a black freedom over everything hoodie
send help boop
and that's it that's the only reason why
i would call law enforcement
only because unfortunately
um a lot of people do not have the
emotional demeanor
and the speak the legalese
to deal with law enforcement officers
from an objective and
logical perspective and so
tensions are high and it could cost
somebody life maybe not even mine i'm
good i can
maneuver with the police easy but the
other five guys around
may not see it the same way i've had a
lot of bad experience with cops
i mean i i've often talked about how i
think most people's interactions with
cops are going to be negative
because you're getting citations you're
going to take it for jaywalking for
speeding headlights out something like
that
and rarely is a cop gonna be there to
actually save you
right but i have been saved i was saved
once from a mugging yeah i had a guy
trying to mug me and it was the
stupidest thing because i was broke my
wallet's empty and i'm like
i'm not even carrying anything dude cops
came out of nowhere it was it was nuts
and grabbed the guy
slammed him up against the fence and
yelled in his face not in my town it was
like really
yeah it was like one of the craziest
experiences i've ever had and that
coming off of i've had cops
give me i've had two i had i got two
tickets
when i was like 20. yeah they were both
bunk i got pulled over and the cop just
lied to the ticket in my face
but even even then i still look at like
with all the riots and everything
what do you what do you do if there's no
police and there's
me just sure yeah in general like let's
let me give you a scenario okay so so
ultimately i feel like i'm for police
reform
yeah we definitely got to figure out
what if the cops are lying and they're
not being held accountable
yeah they got to be held accountable yes
if they're lying under oath we can't
have that
because the system's broken if that's
the case and it happens too much
but i think a lot of what we see in
terms of uh
you know people who get shot because a
cop freaks out we need better training
yep
that means more funding we need uh we
need better programs we if you want
social workers
then i think one of the ideas i think
you had this idea ian like having a
social worker with a cop yeah which
means
adding to the police not taking away
from so i look at it this way
i think there's issues i think we
definitely can have conversations to
reform and figure these things out
we want to make sure we recognize that
cops are people they have their
perspective
they they need to be humans exactly and
i think a lot of them are underpaid
like seriously in new york it's bad so
they don't even care because they're
like for this job i'm not risking
anything
i'm going to shoot first ask questions
later because i get paid 30k a year if
you shoot first ask questions later i
want to hurry up get you your day in
court and send you to jail
right immediately i don't care if that's
an american citizen as a gun owner i
don't go anywhere without a gun
i carry allegedly unlawfully in new york
in new jersey in chicago
and compton and wherever wherever
if anyone that's with me uses their
firearm
shoot first ask questions later i want
my homie to have his day in court
and go to jail okay these bullets
much like toothpaste the bullets don't
go back in the right
you know the rounds don't go back in the
barrel the toothpaste don't go back in
the tube
um so i am going to say the the gist of
what i was saying is yeah i think we
need police
um i think you do but i think that
you don't need as many i think that if
there's less laws
there's too many laws that's true too
the laws
what laws are is a person with a gun
at the end of you not complying to force
you that's why it's called law
enforcement
and if the laws are unjust like slavery
was law
like right this is cool so harriet
tubman going like
nah bro it's a contradiction yeah
they were well within their rights to
kill harriet tubman
if you name if we want to be honest if
we want to be honest as americans
all of our heroes were outlaws
george washington abraham lincoln
malcolm x martin luther king
we were talking about gandhi gandhi all
of these guys
and women were rebels
were like no this is morally repugnant
and incorrect
law enforcement not peace officers like
it used to be not
sheriffs not deputizing constables from
the community
as it should be law enforcement has
turned into a
over militarized racket to
regenerate revenue for the state and
when we have so many laws you're saying
your tickets right
yeah oh your headlight is out come on
bro what like in reality
you giving me a ticket and charging me
money
for that if i didn't get the headlight
fixed i probably don't have money
so you're charging me more money for
having the headlight out and is going to
make the quality of life of americans
better
how i'd like it if your ticket to get
your headlight fixed
you didn't have to pay it if you got
your headlight fixed i think that's
right
but i think they actually do that is it
every time like the problem is you got
to go to court
so they're they're court fees well i
don't know about court fees in these
circumstances but probably
because i've only had a couple
experiences but
i'm pretty sure in many circumstances
like your headlights out get it fixed
and then you go to the court and you
show them you got it fixed and they're
like you're free to go but why
why not police officers just saying hey
man you got a taillight you got a
headlight out
probably because you'll never get it
fixed if there's no if there's no
or or okay if that's the case right if
you won't get it fixed if there's no
incentive let's go with that theory
it just looks trash bro and you'll go
i'll fix it and if there's
like if if i want to drive with one
headlight
like just play it like i'm a motorcycle
a motorcycle has one headlight the
problem is we keep asking the state
to correct us or tell us when we're
wrong
and it ties i know we kind of going out
in the weeds but to bring it back it's
this is why you have more and more laws
where we have to depend on more and more
police to do things that
again if we're talking about taking a
social worker with a police officer
they did that somewhere where like the
the arrests
like dropped or something like that the
reality is we do not need more police
officer or more policing we need more
freedom
we need less laws well i'll tell you
what this is this was a joke tweet but
it's
it's a it's a fact it was like i think
it was like a truthism uh truism
if you abolish all laws there will be no
more crime
right and but here's the other thing
though so look at portugal right
a few years ago portugal was like yo you
want to do drugs
that's on you don't look to us to chase
you about it
don't look to us to help you we'll we'll
redirect some of the money that we have
that we were locking people up for
for this we're going to put it into if
you want to get a rehab
we'll instead of spending x amount for
locking people up
right we're going to spend a fraction of
that for the people that want some help
like once
right yeah the drug war
gone nixon basically created the drug
war to go after
the black community the black um the
black panthers
and the hippies and so he created laws
that he knew they were using
weed and he was way easier it was
already illegal for he was illegal
before that before that first god the
no lie the the the psychological origin
of
cannabis de criminalization in america
was
this one dude that wanted i forget his
name he wanted that one
yeah he said marijuana
makes white women want to sleep with
negro jazz
musicians that is the origin of
cannabis criminalization in america
look it up yeah oh yeah william first
and he had the newspapers he had
paper mills so he was able to print the
propaganda exactly
so sam is to say now okay we're with 40
50 however many years in
did you win this war no and then they
made everything illegal
yeah then they went after lsd and other
drugs in the 60s and 70s meanwhile the
founding fathers owned entire hemp farms
it is a kind of george washington's eyes
on the one dollar bill he looks stoned
it looks like a dude that smoked for 40
years blasted
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you